back to las vegas now the backstreet
boys had a successful residency here in
las vegas and one of the members is now
a resident and he's giving back to a
local charity in a fun way that you can
be a part of i sat down with nick carter
to talk charity karaoke and his love of
this city
you really have embraced this las vegas
community so much and just having you
for a local it's amazing and and cure
for the kids foundation is so good so
what are you a chef now or what's going
on tell us what i am the i am not that
great of a cook i have gotten really
good at grilling but i mean hey we all
say that right um but you know we're
it's it's gonna be an incredible it's
called um uh home for the holidays i'm
inviting people to come into my house
we're going to be two hours live on this
zoom call
and
anybody who goes to cure for the
kids.org and signs up to be a part of it
will get that recipe can cook along with
us with the celebrity chef naisha
arrington and uh billy harris and
raising money for cure for the kids uh
the foundation out here in las vegas
something that it's very dear to my
heart there's gonna be cameras all all
around the house my kids are going to be
running everywhere hopefully you will
keep them in line um and then we're
going to be cooking and then at the very
end um i'm going to be i got this like
karaoke machine and i want to i was like
should i do this like all professionals
try to get like a guitar player like a
flamingo guitar player or whatever and
like no i just got this character
machine so i'm going to sing some
backstreet boys songs at the very end
some holiday songs on this karaoke
machine in front of our tree when you're
not singing backstreet boys what would
your go-to karaoke song be like i don't
know maybe like i have the tiger or
something like that you know
something's really corny i don't know
those are the best ones let me see if
you can do do mine it's easy it's a rap
song so this is my go-to karaoke song
every time just hit the east side of the
lbc better miss you trying to find mr
warranty we've seen a call full of girls
ain't no need to tweak all of you know
what's up with 213. i follow you on
social media i love following you i
think it's interesting to see who the
people i follow who they follow who they
find interesting so i want to bring up
three things that you follow and see why
you follow them okay okay
paul and oates you follow hollow notes
you are you big fans yeah are you
kidding me
are you kidding me like yes like like
holla knows so like that is some of the
best
music and actually you just i i got my i
get stuck on my playlist i'm gonna put
that back on i'm gonna start list when i
get stuck on holonose i'm stuck on them
for like a month
twitch you follow twitch you're a big
gamer right
yeah yes i am actually i have a twitch
channel um i i love playing video games
whenever i can and i play with our fans
you follow the cookie monster tell me
why you follow the cookie monster
um because i want a cookie cookie
that's good enough for me oh cookie
cookie cookie starts with seeds well
maybe you'll be making cookies
yes there's gonna be great desserts at
the at the fundraiser so you gotta be a
part of it tickets are 25 bucks make
sure you get yours and again how do they
get tickets so you just go to cure for
the kids.org you can learn all about it
uh read up on it 100 of the proceeds
goes to families who are in need who who
are dealing with childhood cancer i'm
going to join and i'm going to request
when you do karaoke that you do a whole
note song oh my god that's a good idea
oh my gosh he was so fun to talk to fun
i love it he did the karaoke back to you
with your song